hi i'm greg lewis senior principal
researcher at microsoft research in new
england
and i'm here today with tottenharn a
senior causal insurance expert at toyota
research institute
don liang a senior data scientist at
netflix and yashu a vp and head of data
science at linkedin
we're here to talk about the role of
causal machine learning in the tech
world
and the way i'd like to kick this panel
off is by asking each of you to
introduce yourselves and say a little
bit about how you ended up working in
the space of causal inference and we'll
kick it off with totter and then down
and yeah
thank you greg
so yeah my name is
uh
as greg mentioned i work at the toyota
research institute um the way in which i
got into causality
um i i think it started during my
graduate studies in philosophy
which kind of initially may sound a
little bit strange but actually when you
think about of course uh philosophers
were the were the first ones to really
start thinking about these issues and
it's been a big topic in that field uh
for like 300 years at least
and uh so i started kind of uh looking
into that and got interested in in that
question and then at some point i
realized that well if i want to
kind of
you know
work on this topic i better understand
also how empirical researchers are using
it
and then started looking at that and
soon afterwards realized that actually
this empirical stuff is what i want to
do so
uh then ended up
looking at positions in the tech
industry because it seemed to me at the
time uh uh as the uh to be the area
where these kinds of methods are
uh are relevant and uh applicable and uh
worked for a couple of years at uber and
now most recently i've been uh working
at toyota research institute uh working
on these uh causal inference uh
applications uh looking at policy
interventions experimentation and
anything in between
so just a quick follow-up because i'm
curious when you went to grad school in
philosophy what did you think you were
going to study
um
i
i was broadly interested in kind of
philosophy of science
so scientific explanation and those
kinds of things um of course causality i
ended up kind of arguing in my my phd
that
scientific explanation largely is causal
explanation so i uh that's why kind of
causality became more and more
um important over over time so i roughly
stuck in the in the same area but
what was really um unexpected to me was
uh was this uh increasing focus on
empirical questions and actual
estimation
so i had to study a lot of statistics
and programming during my phd to be able
to uh to move towards that
super interesting i feel like we'll come
back to the question of
what are good stories or what are good
narratives that you can attach to causal
estimates later because i think that's
so important for policy making um but
let's move on to you darwin tell us a
little bit about yourself
oh sure um thanks greg um so i am darwin
i'm a research scientist at netflix
where i mainly work on
personalization algorithms and
recommendation etc so um
i think i first got into
causality
also in grad school around
2014 english
when my
back then my very visionary phd advisor
david bly
he got really into causality um you know
in 2014 actually causality was
definitely not um
as like a widely discussed topic as like
the like like it is nowadays
so um we we read a couple
books and lost a lot of hair and
and the more we we read and the more we
we start to realize actually this is
such a difficult
field in the sense that um it's really
hard to make any like cuddle statement
especially with like observational data
so
um that's roughly where i got started
and also that's
roughly also where we started first to
think um
about recommender system actually as
like um intervention from a causality
perspective which is i mean it's a long
way but it's probably what eventually
led me to hear this panel today
very cool and we're definitely going to
return to the topic of causality
systems
so we'll be back there a second but
let's uh let's ask you how to introduce
yourself
hi uh
and i can introduce them yeah i'm from
ling ding i lead the data science and ai
teams
and uh how did i get into causal
influence i wanted to say that i did not
lose
my hair over causal inference during my
phd
so yeah so i even though that i i did
get my phd in statistics
you may think that i must have studied a
lot of course inference in graduate
school but in the contrary uh because i
went to stanford and the department was
actually very much
applied statistics is very much focused
on statistical machine learning so i was
actually trained in machine learning and
didn't do any causal inference until i
had my first job
so my first job uh was uh
uh in the applying research team
in bing and microsoft and and apparently
i was the very first statistician they
hired and you know when they had causal
problems they naturally think oh yeah
we'll know how to solve this so i i
learned how to solve those causal
inference problems uh when i was at my
first job
uh so from there on uh i
i lost some here i guess uh and then i
moved on to
uh work elling and and at linkedin i uh
put together the experimentation team
and really build our
and uh sort of the the global
experimentation platform um that is
really driving and the large-scale
experimentation that is happening we run
uh hundreds of parallel experiments
every single day at linkedin um
yeah so that's that's my story of how i
got into closing in france
i'm glad that you you didn't have quite
the stressful experience the darwin did
the hair hair loss um
maybe so maybe we're gonna getting into
some of the more detailed questions i
wanted to maybe reverse laura and start
with you that yeah then um
and uh you know in your in your current
job you know you must have a really
high level perspective as a vp and the
way that causal machine learning is used
at linkedin and i'm curious going back
to darwin's earlier point you know it's
really taken off it's a big thing
causing machine learning now how's that
changed for you
over the last few years and and you know
what kinds of skills are necessary in a
company for the data science team to
have what data science group to have to
really change business decision making
yeah the that you're you're absolutely
right it has changed quite a bit um i
you know when when i first started uh
linkedin we barely had any
basic randomized controller experiments
and running right so so i think in the
early days was a lot more focused on
let's just do basic
you know two-sample t-test
and then from there on uh i want to say
one of the
critical turning point was uh about 2016
uh when we
uh
changed our app entirely so in the in
the past linkedin has our what we call
like a sort of old version of our app
2016 was when we uh revamped our
mobile app entirely and and then to do
that we couldn't run a b test anymore
because there is you know you put your
app in the app store and people started
to adopt and that's you know you really
don't have the the luxury of doing a
randomized control experiment and then
so so that was the the initial starting
point when we started to really look
into hey how can we draw causal
conclusion
without uh having the luxury of
randomized experiment uh uh you know
utilized uh doubly robust and uh with
exact matching which is the the method
that we use so that was the starting
point of i want to symbol of the the
causal machine learning
and
we we started and then from there on
obviously we we have gone a long way and
now we we actually do have a
um a tool or platform you may say that
we we we have built various different
causal machine learning um
uh toolkit and methods for people to be
able to just use uh and you know uh
you can they can
obviously if you know feeding some forms
you know drop-downs and um putting their
data and then run a button and is able
to actually give you um some some nice
nice results at least be able to address
uh
uh maybe 80
of a lot of the the
the um observational causal studies that
we need to do um and then certainly
going back to your question of what kind
of skills that's needed so so even for
individuals who didn't come in with a
lot of experience of doing kosovo
machine learning that they are able to
based on the tool to
to to get a lot of the work done but
when it comes to something that's more
sophisticated obviously we need
individuals who usually comes in with a
lot of um
statistical or economics um backgrounds
are individuals who and with the kind of
training that they are able to solve
something that's more sophisticated
so one thing that seems important here
in this story is the development of this
infrastructure right that you now have
this this tool that allows the
um it allows people with many kinds of
backgrounds to easily get results that
are um
that are useful and can be impactful and
sort of making decisions um we're going
to talk about this later when we talk
about a little bit about causal anal and
potentially maybe economical as well
how do you um
what's important what do you think about
when designing this sort of this basic
infrastructure piece uh what does it
need to do in order to make uh data
scientists more effective
um
i want to say first of all really
understanding that
this is still a very
um much evolving field um as well like
there is no sort of one approach that
works for all um so certain approaches
like depending on
the the data that you have depending on
the set of the problem that different
approaches work better right so you know
sometimes the panel works better
sometimes is you know maybe you know you
know bsts work better sometimes maybe iv
works better and then like so so i think
being being able to uh provide a
flexibility and extensibility in the
tools and platforms that you're building
is is really important and and one thing
that we have also learned is we
certainly have a central team that
is responsible for the tool up running
and sort of the core foundational pieces
of the tool but what matters even more
so is
when the platform is extensible that
data scientists who
come up with something new they can on
board onto the platform so that all the
other folks can leverage and use
it can be extremely powerful
and that must be interesting then part
of the job opportunity is to do sort of
maybe some um is to is to find new
techniques that work for your particular
data set and then build them in so
everybody else can use them which i i
we've certainly had this experience in
ecomml as well is that then people who
are working on sort of data science for
particular problems suddenly get to
contribute to the general space which is
kind of a nice opportunity it seems
absolutely um
very cool very very cool
um okay well let me let me ask tata then
um about his work in causal now and
maybe you guys can sort of go back and
forth a bit about about this but i know
that when you're at uber you spend a lot
of time working on that cosmetic package
and it's definitely a package we've
looked at closely here at microsoft
research
can you tell us a little bit about the
oranges of that where did that come from
what problems was it supposed to solve
and and what were the big design choices
you made
yeah absolutely i think it's very much
uh related to what uh you mentioned and
your discussion i think uh you know
part of my job at uber was to build
these uh internal
tools for uh
for various kinds of uh analytics but uh
causal inference in particular
and um
i think um there were kind of um two two
main areas uh one is observational
studies um
where uh where we would have these these
methods like matching and uh and all the
rest and uh and then there was the
question of how to uh
gain better insights from randomized
experiments
and and i found that uh there was a big
difference between those two in terms of
um
the scalability of the approaches in the
sense that
um when we are dealing with
observational studies it is
uh it is uh much more difficult to
kind of release those kinds of tools
for uh
in a big company in such a way that
anyone can
use them because they come with these
assumptions that you would need to
assess and uh
validate and it is simply much more
difficult compared to
tools that built on top of randomized
experiments where
the assumptions are feared um and so
with the course lemon in particular
we uh
this this was mostly a tool that we
built
for the context of randomized
experiments
and
and it was initially used in
uh like marketing context and those
kinds of situations where you would want
to
see how an intervention works for
different
subgroups so it was and still is a
package that is largely focused on that
context of randomized experiments
the some of the considerations that we
we needed to take into account uh
building this tool at uber where
uh scalability of course um we are
dealing with very large data sets with
lots of uh features uh lots of samples
as well so how can we look at randomized
experiments uh where you know we have
millions of users uh and you know
hundreds of thousands of futures
um
and another one was that we wanted to
emphasize was a
uh uniform api for for that uh
library uh such that it's easy and uh
easy for data scientists to use uh it
has a similar api as a scikit-learn
so um so those were the two kind of
considerations that we initially needed
to take into account internally and then
we ended up also open sourcing it and
it's turned out that it's actually
something that's resonated i think in
the in the data science community at
large so it's it's done quite well since
we uh open sourced it in 2019.
so this is maybe a question for both of
you then um when you move from
experimental data
well actually we start with something
slightly different i'm going to i'll
i'll cut tack back to i'll type
observational data but in the case of
experimental data essentially talking
about estimating heterogeneous treatment
effects um and i guess one question is
you know how um
how useful has that been to decision
makers to have some sort of measures of
heterogeneity among the population is
this something that's turned out to be
kind of important in practice or has not
been such a major feature of how how
linkedin and and uber at the time were
making decisions
and i should probably say one you should
go first because otherwise it's hard to
know yeah why don't you speak first
sounds good uh it's definitely helpful
um i want to say that particularly not
necessarily as in
first of all i think it's very helpful
when you have uh heterogeneous trait
manufactures as insights right hey i run
a i launched a new feature
and hey buddy maybe only work uh well
for people in us but it didn't work well
for people
in india um so we certainly have
been able to utilize uh the tool the we
also built similar tools uh that tote
mentioned as well at linkedin to be able
to identify those insights but what's
even more useful for us um is to um be
able to then think about how we can
modify and and evolve our product so
that it works better for everyone
um right so so i think a lot of times
it's very easy for us to
looking at average and be like oh you
know every everything is is better but
then without realizing that maybe it's
actually shifting
the value from one group of population
to another population so it's been very
valuable to us
yeah i i think uh
so so i agree i think uh looking at
these insights uh from past experiments
has been
uh anthony's valuable in the sense that
you can kind of devise some
hypothesis about you know
why it might be that this uh this
intervention that you're testing is or
isn't working i think um
it's tricky with these models though
because you're still looking at
correlations between features and
treatment effects so
so you don't really get to the the
causality with without some further
assumptions
um
[Music]
another um
use case that i actually burn elsewhere
is of course
uh looking more uh into the future so uh
if you have trained this kind of model
for for in and for a certain
intervention then uh it was quite common
to uh build kind of
targeting models that uh that then um
going looking forward for future uh
users can serve these uh interventions
uh in such a way that you know we can
uh expect uh whatever outcome it is that
we're interested in uh to to be uh to be
optimized so so that was of course
another very typical use case for these
kinds of uh tools
uh i can if i can add one more thing
here i think
i think the heterogeneous treatment
effects when you are looking at maybe a
very small
preset and segments and is very
different from if you say hey
i'm just looking for um you know this
large search space
of maybe like multiple dimensions of
continuum um uh their continuous
variable uh so in the in the former is
where you know we did sort of the
insights is really helpful and then we
but then the the latter what we do is a
lot of times we we don't
um and you know this is you may be the
classical multiple testing problem right
so we we don't necessarily just take it
and run with that but but we we would
actually then like test it again right
so if we say hey you know what like
maybe this uh population reacts
differently but we we kind of turn all
the stones and i found this so let's
make just rerun that experiment on those
you know small segment in particular and
see is that just a um you know uh
spurious you know correlation or
conspiracy
uh discovery
or not
yeah i mean that that issue especially
with things being kind of
uninterpretable often you know you kind
of go i got these groups you then want
to check that they're already there in a
little while and then you want to
understand what they even mean even if
you're they're sure that they're they're
statistically it's all what is this
subgroup really and is it you know could
i could i have um could i have divided
my search space in a different way that
would make it more interpretable which i
think is a hard problem i wanted to
bring darwin in though as well because i
feel like uh i know what i want to ask
about you know recommendations on
netflix but i'm also curious about
whether you've had any experience with
uh sort heterogeneous treatment effect
estimation at netflix and what that's
proved important in practice
oh yeah sure so i mean so
um i think at netflix we have probably
um
i guess roughly speaking two different
areas where like
um called like causal inference can be
made useful so one is the one that i'm
more familiar with which is like around
like recommendation personalization from
like a modeling perspective but then
also on the other hand we also have a
very
large group of um
analysts who work on like basically we
run a lot of randomized a b test and
then we need to derive insights from it
and as it turns out like hydrogenous
treatment effect is
um very useful when you try to analyze
like what your a b test has done because
like
both of you have mentioned it's quite
possible that you run a b test and then
you saw that well the the overall result
looks healthy or not healthy or maybe
flat but then when you actually dive
into the the nitty-gritty like different
partition of the user population
different country etc etc you realize
things are not really going in the same
direction and that's where like knowing
about heterogeneous treatment effect
can prove very useful but i mean in the
meantime i think we also
try to be very cautious about actually
estimating hydrogen's treatment effect
because you have much smaller sample
size you need to be more careful about
whether you are making a statement that
actually doesn't really exist so i guess
that's basically um
what i i can add to that
so there's i mean there seems to be
broad consensus that this is very useful
you have to be very careful about how
you do it otherwise you might find
something that's not really there
um and and also ya's point about it
really being about identifying
subpopulations that maybe are not being
well served by your products i wonder if
either any of you actually have sort of
an example in mind of a case where the
products were evolved slightly uh as a
result of what you found for the
heterogeneous treatment effects
um i i can i can share something and we
we certainly
we have fun
um
in a lot of our uh how our communication
channels work with our members
either that is email or notification etc
actually works very differently um
depending on
the the
maybe device people using depending on
the country and the geographic locations
that people are in um so
one example would be let's say we have
people who sign up to get job alerts
when they are looking for jobs they
wanted to be notified as soon as the
jobs uh are posted on linkedin right and
then so because of the delivery
mechanism may be different and then we
gotta just have to make sure that we
optimize um being able to get those uh
sort of the the
essential alerts to to the job seekers
as soon as possible so we have
uh tweaked our
um mechanisms for how we do that based
on the sort of maybe more
geo-based uh results that we have seen
and is this an example of of policy
targeting in the way that toto was
saying that you're going to say this
kind of person in this kind of place
likes to get the job alert by this way
as as maybe distinct from saying
um i'm actually missing a product right
i i see this set of users and these
people are a little happy but this group
is really not happy at all they need a
slightly different product we need to do
market research to even figure out what
we would do to make them happier
yeah i actually also have another
example for that so so many
actually okay maybe like uh
like maybe three years ago
we used to
um on linkedin we have a little referral
button right so if you are applying for
a job you can say i want to get a
referral from and then from that
experiment one thing we notice is that
um people who
have very big network
they are really the ones who are
benefiting um from that referral button
and and then those obviously those who
don't have a strong and no network and
they don't right so so what we decided
is we actually decided to take that
feature off
because we wanted to make sure that we
as we're providing benefits like that we
wanted to make sure that folks
who don't have the higher social capital
um
can still
have that access to the opportunity
equally so
that's a maybe another example
super interesting and i want to return
to this issue of equity and fairness
later because it seems like this is
connected um but i before then i wanted
to talk a little bit about uh
recommendation systems and how causal
reasoning works there uh so yeah tell me
a little about you know what what the
role of causality is in designing
netflix's recommendation system
down yeah sure so um i i guess um
the definition of like actually the
definition of
like causality can actually be either
very narrow um i.e just like estimating
some treatment effect from some
randomized control trial but that can
also actually be very broad and in fact
recently a colleague of mine actually
said that as long as you can
write like the quantity that you want to
estimate or optimize as expectation over
the policies that generate data then
it is causal which is really broad but
actually if you think think about it i
think that's actually quite true and
this perspective
also connects nicely to like a lot of
related fields for example um you know
um in machine learning there are
contextual bandits and reinforcement
learning literature
as well as i guess in statistics about
the missing data theory so i think this
perspective actually connects nicely to
all of those areas as well so i'm
actually gonna go with this more broader
definition um so i guess back to
your question about like
um
how to
make like i guess keep causality in mind
when designing recommended systems um i
guess um
so you might know that actually in the
past like maybe five ten years ago
um in industry
which is actually the time that i was
not in industry yet but i heard those
stories um so um in the in the past
people mostly treat like recommend their
system
um as more like a supervised learning
problem like you collect a bunch of data
and for each user each item you have
some features and you try to train a
predictive model to say well giving
the feature from this user how likely
she or he will like this particular item
and this actually has worked probably
pretty well
um
at first for the first two years but the
problem is basically it might work very
well at first but
um at some point you might you're very
likely to hit a wall um in the sense
that um you try really hard to improve
your of offline accuracy of your
supervised learning model and then you
are very helpful and then you deploy it
online and then you see oops it didn't
actually make any significant change and
actually the more mature your system is
the more likely you're gonna run into
this wall um
and uh
really i think
the reason this is happening is because
you are really not taking like causality
into perspective because when you train
a supervised learning model you are
really making an observational statement
but really when you actually say deploy
your recommender system like say i
recommend a certain title to a certain
user you are really actually doing an
intervention and you are not really so i
guess if you if if if if you are talking
in like i guess the the the pros do
calculus you are actually asking about
the do something intervention rather
than actually just observationally
um giving a new recommendation and
thinking from this perspective i mean it
doesn't really solve your problem but it
kind of opens up the possibility and
also
makes you think a lot a lot harder about
what your recommender system will
actually do to the user
and this will enable you to think a lot
about the problem of for example um the
the positional bias like when you create
a recommended list like if it's a list
then you know people probably are more
likely to click on the thing that ranks
on the top as opposed to the bottom
and also you also likely to think about
um
the the feedback loop so called which is
like your training data for today is
coming from your model
deployed yesterday and this actually
creates a feedback loop which can
potentially be very harmful if you don't
take care of it very well so
again i i guess thinking
causally actually doesn't really like
magically make your problem disappear
but it definitely opens up your mind and
to think
a lot harder around a lot of common
problems that we encounter like in
recommended system
i'm i'm just trying to think through
this logic i haven't thought about this
before so i'm trying to do it in real
time but it feels a little bit like um
we thought that the problem was just to
predict whether you liked the movie or
not and so that feels like a prediction
problem whether you're gonna like the
movie or not but actually you're gonna
do this intervention what you care about
is whether somebody's gonna change their
actions in response they're going to
watch the movie or not
and so when you do this intervention you
do this operation
you know you might change lots of things
and so it's not just about whether
you're going to predict what movies they
like or not but it's like which kinds of
interventions on the system are going to
lead to more people watching movies
which is
a different problem and definitely
causal problem does that sound right
yes i i think but really
i guess one bigger challenge is that
when you think about um
really like estimating causal effect of
a recommended system um you really have
to make a very good
balance between providing
i guess relevant recommendation but also
you need to provide
um i guess you can you can kind of say
like a more trendy recommendation
because you can imagine if you
if you purely think from the perspective
of like causal recommender systems
then you would probably want to find out
the recommender
like the title and that actually can
give you the largest what whatever you
call like the treatment effect i like if
i recommend there this title
this user might watch for this long but
if i don't recommend it it probably will
never watch it but if if you think from
this perspective the problem is you
might actually end up recommending
a lot of title that is probably not very
familiar to this user you imagine when
they log into your netflix and you see a
full screen of title that we magically
know that you will love if you watch it
but when you see that page you were like
what what what's that i um
so yeah it's it's a tricky balance to
really strike as you can imagine you
cannot go full causal but you can also
not go full like observational and
predictive so it's like
yeah you need to think about the balance
of those two
that that balance is super familiar to
me i i actually taught you offline
because i have a paper that's about like
exactly this topic of like things that
look um things that you know are going
to be good but the things the user will
also think are good and you have to get
both of those things you shouldn't say
you've never seen before they don't
agree with you and they don't do what
you want them to do it's an intervention
super interesting um but i'm realizing
we're actually running out of time and
i've got so many questions left which is
just a shame uh let me uh let me quickly
throw this out to the panel when we talk
about observational data and the
challenges of poses and um often it's
the case that you know we're leaning on
unconfoundedness we're leaning on the
fact that you know you're controlling
for everything this must go
spectacularly wrong sometimes um
when when has this gone really wrong and
uh and you know how do you how do you
teach uh data scientists to identify
when things are going horribly wrong so
they don't
come back with you know nonsensical
results
uh and to anybody just jump in
i'm i'm happy to
happy to start uh because you know i
mentioned earlier that we have tools
that uh essentially democratizing
uh you know observational causal
inference and um to many data scientists
who may not be experts in in causal uh
studies
so so a couple things that we do is part
of the tool we do provide a lot of
analysis to make sure
that we evaluate those assumptions um
for example if you have
a
study you're saying hey
sorry
because you know i
something i did today is actually
causing something that i'm doing
tomorrow like you know can you say you
know if i if i also
reverse the variables and then like
somewhat happen to be something you it's
not gonna happen tomorrow is causing
what you're doing today then that's
obviously uh invalid uh uh like you know
invalidate your your study right so we
have a lot of those checks in place uh
so that's number one in the tool
directly uh number two is we also have
this what we call uh sort of a causal
committee where when when the study is
done you know the you know visa report
that actually we have a group of experts
who do take a look at it and review it
um so that just kind of add another
layer um you know people can still use
the tool to
um almost like uh you know to to follow
through ideas and then if as long as
they're not claiming that this is causal
like they can use it to say hey let me
find drivers for this you know these
engagements etc but if they want to just
say this is causal then then the the
committee will kind of have to get their
rubber stamp uh on here to making sure
that it's uh you know those assumptions
are all checked
super interesting that seems like a good
institutional check um
anybody else on this topic or i have
another question which i'll throw it to
somebody different
anyone
um um
go ahead down yeah so sorry i can
briefly chime in because again like um i
guess
like like like i said earlier so when we
think about like um recommend the system
from like a causal perspective it's
probably not really i guess in the
conventional sense of trying to
accurately estimating treatment effect
like make sure everything is
identifiable and also those that kind of
more standard stuff and because none of
them actually can happen in our case
when we have pure observational data and
a lot of uncontrollable randomization um
but one thing that is really
i've heard us a lot in the past is uh
what i i guess so called the time travel
issue which is basically like when you
try to train a dif like well i mean it
sounds cool but it's not as good as the
sun
but anyway
yeah but anyway so as you can imagine
like in the past when you treat um
like a recommended system as like a
predictive problem you want to throw in
as many features as you want and as
possible and sometimes you suddenly see
oh i have such a huge gain there must be
some something really great happening
but then
as you dig deeper you realize oops i
probably include a variable that
actually tells me what happens in the
future but well i try to predict what's
happening in the past for example um i
mean this is purely a hypothetical
example but let's say i take
the feature as like i watch the second
episode of the stranger things and then
the model tried to predict if i watched
the first episode of stranger things
right mother was like okay of course you
have watched the first episode but that
doesn't tell me tell you anything right
so
that's why it's called time travel and
it's not as cool as it sounds but yeah i
think this is like not exactly i guess
fit into the conventional
like causal estimation and that
identification but i think it's like
actually very relevant as well
that's great so okay so i think i think
you know i think what we're learning is
that in fact although we have a large
body of of techniques which are kind of
standardized and well studied in fact
many of the sort of the challenges of of
making systems work well at tech
companies or about other things it's
about institutions and committees that
are reviewing things and tools that are
checking for common errors uh and sort
of you know aspects that are not
directly about are you using
double machine learning versus sort of
on orthogonal forest or whatever right
uh these various kinds of techniques um
i wanted to go next into a topic that
kind of got touched on a little bit by
earlier when she was talking about
product development and there's this
question of equity which is a big or
fairness in tech which is a big big
issue at the moment for good reason
and thinking about how to
design systems that are
treating
all groups equally and i wonder you know
especially as people who are building
tools that estimate heterogeneous
treatment effects
how you guys think about that issue and
how you may implement checks for it
within an organization
and tony maybe i can go to you because
you haven't had chance to speak lately
much yeah
yeah no i think that goes back to the uh
to the discussion that we had about uh
trying to give an interpretation first
of all if you see some differences
uh between different groups uh what is
the what is the underlying
cause and i think here
the
the methods are still lacking a little
bit i think it's
usually some kind of manual process that
that that you go through
to to try to
uh identify uh yeah or try to explain
why uh a certain intervention certain
product might not be working for for
particular groups of people so
uh what is my hope for future research
is that uh that we can build some
systematic way uh of of doing this
uh type of analysis which would make it
more transparent in these cases where we
look at hundreds or thousands of
features and then we would be able to
spot uh
more easily uh what uh
what is the explanation uh for
differences that we might see and if
there is a an explanation that is to do
with
lack of fairness
um so so that's my goal for for future
research um i think uh
another interesting and very relevant
area is uh is is not only kind of like
how we build these algorithms uh in such
a way that we can take fairness into
account i think another one is
uh how we can do analysis with these
methods uh that helps with fairness
um one example in my current work i'm
looking at interventions that help with
uh
climate change or or interventions that
could help to reduce people's carbon
footprint and i think that's a kind of
other way in which we can use these
tools to address issues that uh that are
relevant to to equity and fairness and
those kinds of things so so i think
those are probably two aspects that that
come to my mind uh how we can improve
things with this in this area
broadly
yeah i definitely endorse the the view
that that we can use these tools to
figure out where there are problems and
then and then try to address them which
seems like a huge huge advantage um we
have just a little bit of time left i
thought maybe i'd take give everybody a
minute
to say something about where they wish
would be in 10 years when it comes to
causal inference what are we what are we
hoping for 10 years from now and maybe
i'll
i'll go
uh
yeah darwin taught it
that's such a hard question
i i would just say that in 10 years
joint causal conclusion will be so much
easier
um than it is today uh you know i just
hope that you know we're thinking about
10 10 years ago maybe 15 years ago where
we were with regarding randomized
control experiments very small scale and
to today you know all the big companies
are doing hundreds of experiments at a
time like and i wanted to like be able
to see that with you know non-randomized
experiments as well to be able to do it
at that skill
darwin any thoughts um
yeah 10 years is a really long time but
um i i think right now we are really
starting to like touch the surface of
like thinking of like recommend their
system as
um i guess some might call like a
multi-call causal inference in the sense
that
um you don't have like a single cost
like for each user because first user
you have like multiple titles you can
recommend you can really think of those
as like correlated treatment which might
make this
completely hopeless problem slightly
hopeful and i hope um i think this there
has been a lot of very interesting
development in this area in the last
couple years so i really hope like
like in 10 years we are able to much
better understand um
this whole area and hopefully we will
have a much better way to address
the all the causal problem that we can
recommend the system and from both
actually the predictive part and the the
model and also the evaluation part
okay and tata the last word is yours
yeah i think
there are two two areas so um
so one is that
we
in the tech world of course we are
running all these experiments and doing
all this analysis but i think uh the
vast majority of companies uh are kind
of still catching up and i i'm just
excited to see
when experimentation and these kinds of
methods when they get uh
uh more widely adopted what what comes
out of it so i think uh
many companies are just getting started
and it is really exciting to uh to see
how that goes um another area that uh
that will be very interesting to watch
is um for example right now we are
sponsoring some research that comes from
judah pearl's lab at ucla and
they are developing methods for
combining uh observational experimental
studies to do this kind of estimation
we've talked about uh
conditional treatment effect estimation
for example to to do that more
effectively so i think
for tech companies that's a little bit
untapped how you combine information
from various experiments
with observational data how you start
combining these different types of data
to to do this work even more effectively
so yeah i'm just super excited for for
the next 10 years i don't know where
we're going to be but it's going to be
exciting
well thanks very much to everybody i'm
i'm also very excited about the future
of causal inference i'm looking forward
to a world where
if even if we can't quite get it to the
level of experiments we can at least
sort of have methods that work pretty
well most of the time uh in a large
variety of settings and yeah and maybe
combine that with experiments um thanks
so much to all of you for participating
in the panel it's been it's been a treat
to listen to you and to get your views
um and uh you know i hope you uh help
you
you invent the future in the next decade